[Music]
in our previous lesson we discussed
about air pressure the air pressure is
not even in all the places to understand
this we discussed how the level of air
pressure decreases as we move upwards in
the atmospheric layers now let's see how
the wind speed and air pressure are
related to each other
consider this situation this is point a
we have been asked to move to point B
not a big deal right now from point B
you have to carry this heavy bag and go
back to point a considering this
scenario let me ask you a question
in which case would your body feel more
pressure
practically while moving from point A to
point B you can walk with ease without
much pressure on your body as compared
to this case and what's the reason
behind it this is because you need to
carry only your body weight while going
from point A to point B while in this
case you need to carry some additional
weight while moving from point B to
point a so you automatically reduce the
speed to increase the potential of your
body to carry more weight yes this
reduction in speed will help you carry
more weight whereas the increase in
speed reduces the pressure that your
body can exert the same logic applies to
the moving air that is wind when air
moves with an increased speed the
pressure exerted by it reduces a simple
activity can help us to justify this
fact hold a strip of paper between the
fore finger and the thumb of your hand
blow hard over the top of the paper
strip what do you think will happen well
some of us would think that the paper
will move downwards but what's happening
to the strip of the paper
yes it moved upwards as we blow over the
paper the speed of air increases and
results in low
rusha above the paper strip and what
about the air pressure below the strip
the air pressure below the paper strip
is higher
hence it pushes the paper upwards as
there is a difference in the pressure
exerted by air from these two directions
the net force is acting from the high
pressure area to the low pressure area
so we can see that the increased wind
speed reduces the pressure exerted by
the air likewise there are pressure
differences occurring in nature you may
note that the air moves from the high
pressure region to the low pressure
region for example if there is high air
pressure in region X and comparatively
low air pressure in region Y then the
air moves from X to Y does this mean
that pressure differences create the
movement in air yes that's true the
difference in the air pressure results
in wind but how does the speed of the
wind increase or decrease the answer is
simple if the difference in air pressure
is more between the two regions the air
will move faster the greater the
difference the faster the air moves here
are the two points which can summarize
our discussion high speed winds are
accompanied by reduced air pressure and
next and moves from the region where the
air pressure is high to the region where
the air pressure is low with speed and
air pressure are closely related the
above two points explain the
relationship between the two
[Music]
you